are platforms like facebook twitter and
instagram harming americans in ways that
government regulation could help correct
on thursday february 17th jonathan
height and robbie suave had an oxford
style debate over the role of social
media before a capacity crowd at the
sheen center in downtown manhattan it
was hosted by the soho forum a monthly
debate series sponsored by reason the
soho forum director gene epstein served
as moderator jonathan height professor
of ethical leadership at new york
university and co-founder of heterodox
academy defended the resolution the
federal government should increase its
efforts to reduce the harms caused by
social media robbie suave who took the
negative is a senior editor at reason
and author of the recently published
book tech panic why we shouldn't fear
facebook and the future he argued that
widespread criticisms of social media
stem from our innate and misguided
distrust of new technology suave also
contended that for all of its flaws
social media confers huge net benefits
and that the application of government
force is likely to do more harm than
good hait author of a recent article in
the atlantic on the harm to mental
health from social media pointed out
that while the platforms were not
initially designed for those under 18
they have arguably been its victims
height likened the platforms to sugar
best taken in moderation here's jonathan
height versus robbie suave at the soho
forum
jonathan you have 15 minutes to defend
the resolution come to the podium please
take it away jonathan
well thank you so much gene um
well good evening everyone um i'm i'm
currently hiding away to uh to write a
book called um life after babble and the
the subtitle of it actually could be the
opposite of robbie's it could be why we
should totally freak out about facebook
and big tech and because i'm hiding a
way to write this book i'm saying no to
just about everything i'm really trying
to find time to write
but i said yes to this invitation for
two reasons um the first is because i
was being asked to be paired with robbie
uh who has been an amazing reporter um
since
universities began to blow up around
2015 and greg luciano and i got into
this robbie has been doing just
essential work and he's a great fighter
great a great writer uh and fighter
great fun to fun to read
and i consider him an ally in our common
mission to save universities from
themselves the second reason i said yes
is because i thought about it and i said
you know what
i'm a million
by which i mean a devotee of john stuart
mill
who said
he who knows only his own side of the
case knows little of that
and he said teachers and learners go to
sleep at their posts when there is no
enemy in the field
meaning
we need
critics we need adversaries to keep us
smart and worthy adversaries are the
best kind
so i figured i can't lose because even
if most you vote against me that just
means that i really had a lot of work to
do to understand this and write a better
book so thank you robbie may we learn
together
um i also want to thank uh thank gene
and soho forum for providing this lovely
venue and this setting in which it's
actually fun to argue with people
this illustrates an important point
about the benefits of viewpoint
diversity we don't get smart just from
being exposed to other ideas
if someone yells and screams at you on
twitter and calls you names and attacks
your ideas we tend not to get smarter we
tend to just get more wary or gun shy
learning is highly social much depends
on the institutions and the norms within
which it occurs and that's why i love
universities um uh and it's because of
what social media has done to
universities and so many other
institutions in the last seven years or
so
that i hate social media
now um in fact i have come to believe
uh that a free and open society
cannot continue much longer if social
media continues to damage three things
that i really care about
and those are
young people universities and liberal
democracy
um i'm in my remaining time i'm going to
make the case that social media has
caused devastation in these three areas
since 2012. and then i'll say what i
think government should and should not
do
so i'll make three main points the first
is the fragilization of gen z
so in august 2017 gene twangy wrote an
article in the atlantic with the
provocative title i have smartphones
destroyed a generation
and when i read it i thought wow jean is
taking a risk here because she showed
these graphs with these hockey stick
curves
but it was just two or three years of
data because in 2017 all we had was data
up throughout 2015 and so we had two or
three years showing up turns in all
these things and i thought if that turns
down she's going to look foolish
but it didn't turn down it kept going up
and up and up
now when that article came out there
were a lot of critics a lot of people
said oh she's exaggerating she's
cherry-picking oh the trend isn't real
you know gen z they're just comfortable
talking about it that's why the numbers
are going up a little because it's a
good thing they're willing to admit that
they're depressed
um so there are a lot of skeptics right
after the article came out and robbie in
his chapter on this on this uh uh uh
area quotes a number of those skeptics
but those are all from 2017 at least
most of the citations were from 2017
that was a legitimate take in 2017 but
in the in the years since then the
numbers have gone up so far uh that the
the surgeon general recently issued an
advisory on on teen mental health
because those numbers have gone up by 50
to 100 percent in many uh on many many
measures
in fact
if you're still skeptical that there's a
real epidemic of mental illness if you
think it's just oh you know changes in
self-report on surveys let's look at
behavior
i've been gene and i have been
collecting all the studies we can find
from the u.s and the uk and canada
and so here are the numbers for
self-harm and this is hospital
admissions this is not self-report
hospital records for teenagers brought
in because they harmed themselves mostly
cutting themselves
if you graph it out the lines are pretty
stable they don't move around very much
up until about 2009-2010
and then suddenly in the next five years
the numbers are up 62 percent for older
teen girls the rate of hospital
admission per 100 000 in the population
is up 62 percent
for girls age 10 to 14
these are little girls these are
pre-pubescent or just entering puberty
girls
the rate is up 189
by 2015 nearly triples by 2015 and it's
up more since then same thing in the uk
same thing in canada and similar story
for suicide there it's up for both boys
and girls and again for the youngest
kids the 10 to 14 the percentage
increase is more than double in a few
years the suicide rate has doubled and
then it stayed
either level or increasing
now what caused it that's the key thing
now robbie and the other skeptics point
to studies there are a lot of studies
out there and many of them find no
relationship between the amount of time
young people spend on their devices and
their rates of depression
now there's a one particularly
influential study by andrew
schabilski and amy orban 2019 they
reported an overall correlation of
around .03
between time on devices and various
measures of depression in three large
data sets and that study where they
reported oh this is about as big as the
correlation between mental illness and
eating potatoes that finding got a lot
of press all over the world and since
then a lot of experts say oh well you
know we looked at this and there's
nothing there
but here's the problem with those
studies they lump all kids together that
is boys and girls
they lump all screen activities together
including watching netflix texting with
your friends facetime browsing the web
oh and posting photos of yourself in a
bikini for people to make comments about
you just lump them all together and you
find a 0.03 correlation but guess what
if you take the same data sets and gene
20 and i did this take the same data
sets use the same statistical techniques
but you zoom in on girls and social
media the correlation isn't 0.03 it's
0.2
which is a very large correlation in
public health matters the correlation
between exposure to lead in childhood
and adult iq is 0.09 public health is
all about effects around 0.05 to 0.15.2
at the most this is a as big as anything
else we worry about
now of course correlation is not
causation robbie points out but we've
collected we found about 15 experiments
in the great majority of them also using
random assignment find effects on mental
health um you want more evidence ask the
girls that's what facebook did in that
study that was leaked last september
and what do the girls say they say it
loud and clear it's social media and
especially instagram as one girl in the
uk said the reason why our generation is
so messed up and has higher anxiety and
depression than our parents is because
we have to deal with social media
everyone feels like they have to be
perfect
point number two
from curiosity to fear in universities
so crucial part of my story is that
social media was not toxic
in its original formulation you put up
links to your friends your favorite
bands in 2004 2005 it was not toxic
everything changed beginning in 2009
when facebook ads the like button and
twitter copies it twitter adds the
retweet button facebook copies at the
share button and then other platforms
copy them and now you have so much
engagement data that you can use
algorithms to feed stuff to people based
on what will engage them which means
emotions which means especially anger so
everything changes between 2009 and 2012
we get a much more this is when facebook
perfects that business model based on
advertising and gluing people to the
screen by having viral emotional content
that's when everything changes 2009 to
2012.
one of the engineers at twitter who
worked on the retweet button was quoted
a couple years ago as saying
he regretted what he did because twitter
became a nastier place immediately he
said when he watched those first twitter
mobs form he said we just gave a loaded
gun to a four-year-old
and that's where we are that's why call
out culture and uh and victimhood
culture but call it culture in
particular emerges in the early 2010s
that's what greg luciano began to see
on campus in 2014 when gen z arrives on
campus around 2013 2014 kids born in
1996 or seven or later greg begins to
see this weird pattern this
vindictiveness this fragility this
attack mode it wasn't there in 2012 but
by 2014 2015 it was intense and it was
scary and it changed our behavior
we've done a lot of research at
heterodox academy on attitudes what we
find is that students are afraid to
speak on campus because they're afraid
of not their professors other students
and professors feel they're walking on
eggshells not because of other
professors because of students it's not
most students most students are lovely
they want to learn they want to be
challenged but there are enough around
that make it so that we all have to walk
on eggshells as deb masik said i'm sorry
is that five minutes left to in my okay
okay
um as deb masik said uh
executive director of hedorax academy
one of her students said my motto is
silence is safer
what a sad motto for a college student
the third point very briefly is the
achilles heel of democracy
plato said that democracy is the second
worst form of government because rule by
the deimos the masses or the mob
inevitably decays into tyranny so the
founding fathers of this country gave us
all kinds of mechanisms to slow down mob
dynamics well needless to say it didn't
work very well after 2009
so i'll skip ahead and we can talk about
this later um but basically democracy
has a known achilles heel a known spot
like on the death star where you know if
you get hit that spot it's going to blow
apart and it is our the ease with which
we are divided into factions that hate
each other so much we don't care what
happens to the country
uh social media especially twitter but
also facebook and others have really
targeted that spot now
what can we do the resolution here is
not
congress shall regulate
i really enjoyed robbie's book i
recommend it to you he's such a clear
writer he goes through every possible
issue that people talk about and you
find out there's a lot of
misunderstanding of what's going on he
also points out just how terrible
congress is at regulating and some of
the ideas proposed you know by holly and
others you know they're specifying micro
specifying and you know after 30 minutes
they should be kicked off i mean these
are stupid stupid bills
so if i was defending the motion
congress shall regulate i would just say
well it's hopeless and and i'm going to
go jump in a lake um but
what we're talking about here is do we
have a national emergency do we have a
gigantic problem facing our young people
our democracy and our institutions and
if so
a lot of it is commons dilemmas like
prisoners dilemmas things that are hard
to resolve if you're one person for
example
many of your parents many of you have
kids
raise your hand if you want your your
children to be on instagram raise your
hand if you think that's a good thing
for them okay raise your hand if your
kids are on instagram
okay not many parents here maybe not
among libertarians but
okay
okay i can't see with the lights in my
eyes take it from me all of us parents
who who let our kids on instagram it's
only because they say but everybody else
is on and i'll be excluded if i'm not on
it so we're caught in a trap and we need
central leadership to break it in
particular
what kids most need is delay entry the
copper bill that set the age of internet
adulthood it was originally going to be
16 was the original bill from ed markey
lobbyists got it down to 13 and back in
1996
that's at that age you're like an adult
that was a terrible idea and now we know
the age must be raised i think it should
be 16 or 18. these are minors and we
need to enforce it there needs to be
some kind of age verification
so there are a number of urgent things
that have to be done the uk is making
some progress perhaps they'll take the
lead here but i think we need to do it
in this country too protecting democracy
is much harder i grant because the
things the left wants to do and the
things the right wants to do are often
opposites uh so perhaps we'll talk about
specifics later but i do think we need
to look into ways to encourage the
platforms to do identity verification
um
uh but especially here's the main thing
changes to the architecture i don't want
a government agency either making
decisions about what you can say what
you can't say that would be a disaster i
have so many libertarian friends i've
been semi-brainwashed just by osmosis
i don't want the government making
decisions about what people say
but there are changes to the
architecture and the virality that's
where we can have big impacts that are
content neutral politically neutral and
language independent they work all over
the world
so in closing
instagram and tick tock are raising our
children
our children are spending more time with
them than they are talking to us and
those platforms channel the enormous
force of peer pressure and peer norms
onto them
facebook and twitter are running our
public square and they are curating what
passes for deliberation in our
deliberative democracy
how's that going well now in 2011 we had
the height of techno-democratic optimism
we thought these things would be a boon
to democracy
but now we know they were pandora's box
and we unwittingly unleashed demons we
can and we must find ways to tame them
thank you
robbie suavey
15 minutes for the nether
[Applause]
all righty hello everybody thank you
gene so much for
organizing this debate it is my great
honor to have this conversation with
jonathan height one of my my heroes one
of my uh intellectual inspirations it's
actually my great honor and sort of my
great terror to be doing this uh when we
originally envisioned this debate i
won't say who but i was going to be
debating someone else that i felt a
little bit more
confident against and then when when
height got swapped in i was like you
have to be kidding me the world's
foremost expert on the narrow topic
we're going to be discussing great
thanks a lot gene
nevertheless uh here i i will make my my
best attempt so i'm going to be begin by
reading to you three quotes
that i think will
capture
the the concern and the criticism of
social media so three quotes about
social media
this is from the dutch sociologist
ernest vandenhag say and he says of
social media it's taken everywhere from
seashore to mountaintop and everywhere
it isolates the bearer from his
surroundings from each other from
reality and from ourselves
here's another quote from the charlotte
news it's keeping children their parents
up late at night wearing down their
vitality for lack of sleep making
laggards of them at school
and then finally from the new york times
our very small children will fear to
express themselves who will be willing
even to express any but the most
innocuous and colorless views so you may
have guessed by the language of these
quotes these do not refer to social
media the first was in reference to the
radio in 1963 the second was also
reference to the radio 1926 and then the
final quote from the new york times
that's actually from 1898 and it refers
to the phonograph
later in that editorial the new york
times writes something ought to be done
to mr edison
and
there's a growing conviction it ought to
be done with a hemp rope
this was the level of hostility to new
forms of communication that
uh have have been so common throughout
our history often moral panics fostered
by the existing media structure because
who loses out who loses your attention
if your attention is now taken up by
radia by radio perhaps the new york
times that same dynamic is underway
today so much of the most righteous
indignation and condemnation of social
media actually comes to us from the
traditional media the existing media
from cable news from newspapers from
magazines
from other other things other
communications platforms that are losing
that fight for your attention they hate
it they're against it they want to come
up with all sorts of reasons why this is
bad for society why why the flaws we see
in them are actually worse on social
media
so i think that's always something to
keep in mind when these arguments are
being advanced often by stakeholders by
the the losing out technologies or the
technologies that are harmed by these
emergencies that are not new that we've
dealt with over and over again so i
first became interested
in this topic because i remember
the the handwringing the the panic over
uh video games violent video games when
they appeared i was an active gamer as a
teen and we were we were promised that
there needed to be
rules laws regulations to stop violent
video games from getting into the hands
of teenagers because we were told it
would increase violence among young
people we now know that is totally wrong
that if anything i i i think i'm not
saying anything wrong on uh
social psychology grounds but i suspect
the small amount of teenagers inclined
to really horrific violence actually
tend to find an outlet amongst violent
video games it would discourage them
from actually creating violence so that
that was but there was a certainty that
these this new technology was so harmful
and so scary and so bad so i you know i
take that all of that prior history we
have of these platforms
all of these inventions as we explore
this topic so the the contention for for
a while from uh from john and from gene
twangy who's you know work i find very
interesting and i encourage everyone to
look at it and i've looked at
these studies which john has compiled a
whole document looking at exactly what
these studies showed how many of them
going through them fielding criticism
about them responding to it
and i you know the the broad claim is
actually one that um twangy has i think
retreated from somewhat the broad claim
initially being that screen addiction
was the concern that kids just on their
phones on these new platforms all the
time was
maybe making them not sleep well at
night increasing their depression for
various ways now we've kind of stripped
some of those
some of those concerns away because now
we see that well young boys aren't
having nearly as much of the same
negative experience perhaps the the ways
they're using social media are not
particularly unhealthy
video games again can have an actually
a healthy experience
they're cooperative they're
collaborative they're storytelling they
do them with their friends they stay
connected with people
you know just streaming just watching
videos and reading articles is not
necessarily harmful for for young people
so we start to get at a very very narrow
problem which i i agree is a problem
worth exploring and talking about how to
solve which is that one platform
specifically not screens in general not
social media in general but one platform
instagram
seems to be having a negative effect on
not the majority of teenage girls but
some
some a specific demographic some users
were reporting that in survey data to
facebook again it was not most of them
it was it was
less than half saying they were having a
negative experience on the platform yes
can you
cause can you correlate this with um
with the increasing mental negative
mental health outcomes how young people
are reporting
i i see that correlation i it's
certainly not ridiculous but now again
we're just talking about one platform
one group that is having some problem
with it even the majority of people in
this group not having a problem with it
perhaps using it to stay connected with
their friends
staying
having normal healthy amounts of use we
this is something we tend to see in the
in the data in the surveys that you know
teenagers who are using social media a
moderate amount are doing fine those who
are using it all the time are having bad
outcomes those are who are not using it
at all also having bad outcomes because
that tends to mean they don't have a lot
of friends they don't have people to
interact with and that can be depressing
and sad being a teenager is sad and is
hard it to kind of no matter what i i
bet if you surveyed all of those 10 to
14 year old girls about
like does school give you a positive
experience you get like a 90 no rate uh
my my suspicion is
a lot of
unhealthy kind of culture of difficulty
of being a teen might be channeled into
this one specific platform
that is not so great sure
uh the the good news is we don't really
need the government to solve this
problem because
facebook which owns instagram is rapidly
declining in popularity it is
hemorrhaging users uh so facebook the
main platform is dying of its own accord
it cannot attract young people to it the
kinds of uh
people who do use it tend to be too old
which is no good for advertisers
it wants to be that new cool exciting
thing that young people love and spend
all their time on it just isn't anymore
and this i think goes to the uh maybe a
larger sort of ideological argument i
have that you're gonna get the
government in here to do something about
it by the time they do like this will be
over it'll be some new platform i think
there's already considerable evidence
that you know even instagram is not
holding the youngest of the young
people's attention anymore it's been a
vast migration to tick tock tick tock is
now has surpassed google i believe it's
the number one like visited site i so
we're still waiting i i think i correct
me if i'm wrong john to get data
specifically on how how tick-tock is
influencing this age cohort i suspect it
will be more positively tick-tock unlike
instagram is a bit more creative and i
mean there's
i don't know how how old the average
person in the audience is they're tick
tock's a little too too young even for
me
but you people like do dance videos and
they they you you create things with
music and it's a little bit more
uh creative than the just like
you know i don't know attractive picture
of yourself on instagram that can make
you feel bad about yourself if you're
doing social comparison to that sort of
thing so i i i think we you know we
might be passing the instagram
moment
kind of
on our own without the government having
to do anything about it so that's my
sort of grand argument against
that specific area in which john is very
knowledgeable and has introduced a lot
of things that i think you know people
should be concerned about i also
totally agree that parents should feel
empowered to
not have their kids on social media to
take the phones away not have them in
the in schools in in the in the bedroom
at night um you know i was limited to
one hours of video games on weeknights
when i was a kid and that was a
perfectly fine rule because i would have
just done it all the time and yes
parents should make that i'd love to
hear from parents about how we can make
that easier but i doesn't seem like it
doesn't call out for a government
solution in fact and this would be my
argument against some of the age
restriction type things john is talking
about
it seems to me that probably the best
way to preserve interest in instagram
would to me make it like
sexy and dangerous and scary like you
might die if you use it the government
won't let you have it
that could actually like drum up or
increase interest in it why don't we
just like let it kind of stop being cool
on its own as i suspect it will be as
all prior social media sites eventually
do i was using myspace and aol instant
messenger when i was a kid they are gone
you can't and visit them i don't think
um
so that's the that's the harms to kids
kind of category and then also if we if
we're empowering the government to do
something about social media which is
the question here
we have to think about so
the government is going to stop the
harms caused by social media well right
now the government is doing that the
government is trying to stop the harms
that the government thinks are caused by
social media and that is you posting on
facebook questions about the efficacy of
mass mandates and whether kovit actually
emerged from a lab the federal
government is actively trying to
suppress those conversations by
coordinating and communicating with the
major tech platforms to have a vast
crackdown in events of silencing on
speech the tech ceos are hauled before
congress every few weeks to answer
ridiculous questions from democrats and
republicans questions that betray a
complete lack of understanding of these
technologies uh
that and called to account for both
taking down too much content which is
the republican criticism and not taking
down enough content which is the
democratic criticism uh the the
solutions the proposed solutions often
produced by these discussions
and i'm talking about things like
breaking up the tech companies or uh
changing section 230 which is the
liability protection enjoyed by these
sites uh are are very bad solutions i
suspect uh in fact changing the
liability protection is a solution so
bad that facebook has now come out in
support of it as a way to prevent its
nearest competitor twitter from from
beating it
facebook understands that if you raise
the liability threshold for social media
sites well facebook which
hires an army of content moderators will
be in a better position than twitter
which has many fewer content moderators
and twitter told me when i
interviewed people from this book they
said yes we are dead set against this
this will kill us
uh it you know it's reflective of the
kind of industry capture that that can
happen when powerful companies get
involved with the government and and do
you know practical uh things that they
say are the best interest for everyone
for the consumers these sites are so
harmful we need the government then it
ends up being something that just helps
one company um
over another so i i do not think
it's a good idea and then we also have
to worry about even if we're just
concentrated on the harm to kids part of
it maybe we'll get into you know some of
the other stuff uh during q a or with
each other we do have to like the first
amendment exists i don't think the
federal government should do things that
violate the constitution we already know
that attempting to ban uh or restrict
violent video games the ability for for
kids to purchase violent video games
there was a law in california to stop
that the supreme court struck it down
much of what we're talking about is pure
speech and i think the supreme court
honestly frankly would have something to
say about efforts to prevent even young
people from having access to speech
speech is the most protected thing the
thing that is most protected by our by
our bill of rights by our kind of
american system i'm sure we'll get into
some of the dysfunction the horror that
we're live in the tribalization that
we're living through and it is it can be
ugly out there on social media i know
that just as well not better than
everyone in the audience um it can be
bad i i don't know and i'm i'm skeptical
that social media is the cause of this
dysfunction of this anger of this just
like hor our horrifying politics um i i
suspect it is a outlet but the like the
the anger and the wrath
is mostly due to the actual like
behavior of our political parties and
how they treat each other like you see
partisan screaming and lies and horror
if you watch cable news i no matter
which cable news you're you're a fan of
you will see it on either side against
the other team again that's not social
media that's existing media the and the
the biases and the misinformation
peddled by traditional news outlets and
cable news
are really bad
like it's funny when they're saying that
well facebook is the reason mark
zuckerberg you know uh mark zuckerberg
is the reason donald trump gets elected
because of you know facebook
interference that kind of stuff thinking
have you watched cnn or fox news these
are 24-hour uh commercials for or
against pure propaganda for or against
one specific candidate uh there's
evidence that people are
you know despite our concerns about the
bubbling effect the siloing effect
people actually are more likely to
encounter information they might
disagree with more than we expected on
social media there's again it can be
very bad
there's a lot like wrong in our society
right now i don't think social media is
the cause of it i think social media
came along as these things were
happening and there can be bad things we
should think about how to improve how to
improve our lives tune these things off
if they're a problem for you keep them
away from your kids it is not a is
something for the government to do there
is no evidence we should have no faith
that the government can do anything
and
the government is a cause of much of
this dysfunction in the first place
thank you
uh five minutes of rebuttal
five minutes every battle jonathan
height okay
uh well thank you robbie um there's very
little in what you said that i that i
disagree with i mean again your book is
wonderful and you go through the
objections and it's always complicated
and you've raised valid concerns about
all the uh the problems that i've raised
and the solutions that have been
proposed um i i do want to start though
by talking about your description of
this as a moral panic you're absolutely
right this is a moral panic amazingly
similar to the previous ones you're
absolutely right about that um i really
enjoyed your description of what
happened when bicycles came out um you
know there's a moral panic about that
but
skeptics skeptics of the of of my
position almost always point out the
long history of moral panics but that
argument to say that that's an argument
against what i'm saying
that relies on what's called the
survivorship bias
and that's where
if you interview survivors of shipwrecks
in ancient greece and you find that
almost all of them prayed to god you
would say wow you see
praying to god works
because of course you're not
interviewing the ones who prayed to god
and died
okay so now robbie's right that these
communication technologies
almost all of them were objected to like
this but those are the survivors those
are the ones that we still have like the
printing press the radio uh phone well
phonographs but these you know these are
technologies that we that survive that
we love and in some cases we had to tame
what else is there
well how about things like leaded pipes
like leaded pipes that was an amazing
invention by the romans and it allowed
it you know allowed them to build cities
it was a great technology and we used it
all the way into the 20th century even
though some people kind of knew even the
romans that this is actually making
people sick
we didn't get led out of pipes and paint
and and gasoline until really the 1960s
and it took federal legislation because
there are all kinds of advantages to
businesses for using it as a product it
it increases the the power of gasoline
so
there are all kinds of technologies that
we did object to they were causing real
harm
and i put it to you based on what i've
seen based on the studies that i'm
surveying here
i think
social media is leaded gas and leaded
pipes for today's children
causing i believe permanent changes in
their level of mental illness
how about the tommy gun that was a
pretty great innovation it could shoot i
think 600 rounds in a minute a really
real marvel of technology and it was
very useful to a lot of people but it
had some external costs that it opposed
on society and empowered mobs as it were
it took federal legislation to say no
we're not going to allow this technology
for anyone
and so i put it to you that you know
twitter is the tommy gun of of today
so that's the point there about the
about the previous social panics um on
robbie point made it sound as though the
issue here is just instagram and that's
going away but i think that's not that's
not the case it's true instagram is
uniquely bad for girls um tick tock i
agree with you it's not as harmful pound
for pound but it's also so much more
powerful there are deep pockets of tick
tock girls are actually getting
tourette's syndrome because they watch
videos about tourette's syndrome and
then they develop tourette syndrome so
i'm expecting tik tok to have a lot tick
tock's funny and it's fun but also i
think it's going to do a lot of damage
the issue here is not a platform it's a
business model the business model of
advertising driven
the user is not the customer get them on
and keep them on i think we should
protect kids from that i'm very loath to
tell adults what they should do but i
think there's now evidence that kids
should be protected from platforms that
use this particular business model
um then finally i'll just make the point
that robbie was talking about data that
almost all of this debate here in the
scientific literature is using a dose
response model treating social media
like sugar oh well you know but if you
have more social media or non-social
like you know if you have there's an
optimum amount of sugar that you should
eat that's just like you take it in it
affects you but social media is a
rewiring of society for everyone
especially for all kids between
2009-2012 before then kids went to each
other's houses they they looked at each
other they spoke after that you go into
any school now at recess or between
classes no one looks at each other
because they're all on their phones all
the time i talk to cousins and nephews
that are in college they can't meet
anyone you can't talk to anyone because
they're all on their everyone is hooked
so um so think about network effects
both for children and for democracy and
finally robbie said um
you know if you ask a 14 year old girl
today does school make you feel good um
well gene and i did a study on that we
found a data set the pisa data set and
um it turns out loneliness in school was
stable from 2002 to 2012 it was stable
and then all over the world in all
regions of the world loneliness of
school goes up after 2012. so it's a
gigantic global network effect it's hard
for kids to talk to other kids because
they're too busy performing on social
media platforms thank you
[Applause]
i guess the only
thing i would add to that or push back
on
yes uh it it can be annoying to walk
into a room and see everyone on their
phone people should put down their
phones more spend more human contact is
good i'm all in favor of it this
pandemic has reminded me how much i
prefer it
to social media although we should keep
in mind that we are i think lucky that
we did have social media as we went
through this again it is no substitute
for actual human socialization but
because of massive external factors we
were told by our government that for
people's health you are not allowed to
socialize you're not allowed to do the
most fundamental healthy human thing
imaginable you must you know not like
breathe on people you have to stay away
from them
and i i i suspect that it's good or it
was a positive that we at least had this
to fall back on or i mean if we're
defining social media broadly this
includes the things that actually made
our lives like literally possible during
the pandemic
zoom clubhouse
netflix streaming et cetera
also when you do walk into a room
yes everybody on their phone it's
annoying but it's not like everyone
who's on social media is not
communicating i mean much of what
they're doing is in fact socializing
it's socializing with other people it's
not people in the room with them
currently but there's other people it
can be people all over the world i've
met people because of social media
because of forums and various things
that i would have never had the
opportunity to engage with these people
uh if you know i was confined to just
the my immediate vicinity i mean the
social media is a very uh liberatory
technology in in terms of its ability to
connect people across vast distances i
know that's like the starry-eyed uh
vision of social media but still true to
a to a large extent um finding a social
media can be a way for teens to find
sympathetic ears to find to find healthy
communities sometimes they find
unhealthy communities that can happen
but they can they can find healthy ones
uh as well
so so we we it's not you know it's not
literally like everyone on a social
media site is just like a lost zombie
human who is no longer engaged uh in the
realities of life and also there's you
know we can talk about um the the the
mental
health crisis the worsening of it i i'm
certain we will find an even worse
mental health crisis
among young people you know when we're
counting the most recent years for again
totally exogenous factors the the
pandemic and the shutting down of
everything that like kids hold dear
extracurricular activities school their
hub of their social lives
so so i
i totally understand and and agree that
there's a huge mental health crisis and
and problems i think some of it john
addressed that in his earlier comments
you can't just say it's people
being more willing to be open about uh
mental health i think that i like we
might disagree on how much of that it
explains i'm a big fan of jonathan
height and the coddling of the american
mind where they predicted that when when
you make it so that in in liberal
activist circles the person who is the
most oppressed and traumatized has the
most power you will create a system
where people compete to sound like they
are oppressed and the easiest way to
like fake oppression if you don't fall
into like a category where you might
have experienced negativity would be to
say well i have a mental illness i've
recovered from ptsd i'm traumatized for
various reasons and i i do think that
explains some not all not all at all uh
by any stretch of the imagination
explains some of the we've almost like
destigmatized mental health a little too
far where people want to see themselves
as traumatized and victimized and i
don't think that's a healthy thing but i
don't think that's social media yeah i
think that's the kind of
cultural trend among among young people
among young activists uh the last thing
i i want to say before i return to my
seat
it is still important to keep in mind
you know let's
as we talked about instagram in those
hearings right the wall street journal
report instagram's so bad again
newspaper very anti-social media uh
we're liking
instagram uh facebook to big tobacco
this is the big tobacco moment you heard
that over and over again
big tobacco has killed millions of
people
how many corpses can we lay at
facebook's door actually i accept that
it's more than zero is it millions it's
definitely not millions
so
and also unlike cigarettes which have no
positive except i mean if it's positive
if you like smoking them but
like kids all sorts of vices have
declined along this the rise of social
media so so like drunk driving rates
among teenagers have fallen off it's 54
decreased since the early 90s kids spend
more time on their phone they they
gather less there are good and good
effects of that there are there are some
like we so we have to stack up like all
the lives saved by kids not getting into
messy circumstances
drug use alcohol abuse all down among
the same age cohort along the same time
frame that social media comes along so
it's not always good when kids are only
looking at their phones i agree but
it is good if it stops them from like
killing themselves in a car
thanks to you both we now move to the
question and answer part of the evening
and we do have a mic over there and then
for the people on the balcony we have a
mic
pointing approximately the direction
where the mic is and so we're going to
alternate that way
the moderator i have
the prerogative to ask questions but uh
the rules are that either of you can lay
a question on the other at any time uh
do uh you either want to either if you
want to do that or you want to wait for
audience questions uh uh
john i'm now please pick up the
microphone jonathan you wanted to put a
question to your opponent please go
ahead yeah
my partner um so
just one question
so we we have we have this big change in
teen mental health it begins like in
2012 2013 uh you know something's a
little early a little later but like
it's like right there
just as
as as american teens move on to these
platforms
if it's not that
what is it
the critics the people i debate with
they never give an alternative there's
no plausible alternative i've heard for
why suicide rates doubled a few years
over the next few years
i don't know i think the uh the 2010s
are
probably a just a more depressing
horrible time than
like the 1990s i'm being totally serious
um
kids are stressed out about some of the
things they're stressed out about i
don't think are maybe as legitimate or
to be worried about but they're worried
about climate change they're worried
about you know the the promise of going
to college and you know you could taking
out loans and then you pay them back
because you get a good job that like
there's some instability in in the kind
of economic uh situation for them that i
i think things were more chill and
relaxed in the 90s um
like i think that's kind of true there's
it's hard to put your finger on what
exactly it is but like the last 10 years
have been a worse time i think that
crime is up uh it is actually up people
used to be right misinformed about crime
and now like their perception that crime
is raising is finally correct
uh
which is not to discount that social
media's had something to do with it i i
can buy that a little bit but
i don't i it seems to be happening at
the same time rather than the direct
cause to me here we're left like
interrupt each other right
like you know have like a normal
conversation
okay so yes in the last few years i
think you can make the case that things
are objectively worse on some measures
but put yourself back in 2012 2013 2014
we had the global financial crisis in
2008 or so the bottom dropped out young
people thought they had no future um and
over the following years after about
2011
the economy gets better and better
unemployment drops more and more the
stock market goes up and up everything's
looking up so how does it get better for
this age group though does it get better
for the people staring this down
but why would but why would an improving
economy affect why economic changes
affect girls more than boys right why
would i mean the timing just doesn't
work for it to be economic factors and
in terms of it being scary things in the
world when big scary threats happen you
know what happens generally to suicide
rate it drops durkheim found that in the
1890s when you go to war people don't
say oh my god where i'm going to kill
myself no anything any sort of
collective crisis brings people together
and that protects against suicide
suicide happens when people feel
disconnected alone alienated not when
there's a common threat and if young
women in particular we should be clear
about this you see the graphs it's not
just young women it's young women on the
left
just in the last six months two data
sets have come out
all k all kids are getting more
depressed but it starts first for young
women who say they're on the left and
it's steepest for them
um and so
uh i would suggest to you that it's
because they all got on social media and
it's the progressive girls who are all
freaking each other out about as you
said victimization global warming
oppression
rape culture all these things um so
even if it's the external world it's
brought into them by social media every
day while they're awake but they could
freak themselves out about that without
social media
not as much i mean when i was a kid we
would get angry about things the
republicans did and there was like one
or two every week
you know now it's like every hour well
but it is this is a much more
politically vicious time that is another
major way in which this is just a worse
time like our politics are so broken and
so horrible
you know choices that political actors
have made like that didn't have to be
made um that i mean like the inability
to talk about anything other than donald
trump for five straight years really
sucked back for everyone's psyche no
matter if you love him or hate him it's
bad for your psyche uh but but i i mean
like i'm not dissenting from the
instagram part of it um so
okay do you have a question for me we
might do you want to put a question to
johnny
i'll let the audience okay yeah okay
well uh please uh don't have to identify
yourself uh please just uh ask your
question as a question and if it's
directed to either of the two debaters
please state that as well go ahead take
it away sir uh thank you sir um this is
directed to jonathan i interested uh i
was very interested in what you had to
say
i think at the heart of what you said
was that
anxiety in first among young girls said
increase had tripled
uh and that the analysis you had done
had showed that there was a 20
correlation with
involvement with social media yeah a
0.20 correlation yeah that's 20
well okay
okay i'm a statistician so i do know
that
um i i'm not sure that you understand
that what you were saying was that four
fifths
of that tripling was due to
at a at least due to something else and
that at best one-fifth
of that tripling was due to involving
social media if there was causation and
i'll get to that in a moment so what you
were saying was that one-fifth of the
tripling which would be a little more
than one-third increase so that
depression anxiety among young girls
increased by about a third during the
period which is worrying but really i
think if that's all it is it explodes
your claim that this is some giant
tripling of anxiety
at best if there's causation it's only
increased by one-third because of uh
involving social media now now now now
now let me just finish let me just
finish
because as you know and as you've heard
many times correlation does not mean
causation it could be that all those
other things which you haven't attempted
to identify that cause four-fifths of
the increase
are getting these young girls be anxious
and first and
by pure correlation they happen also to
go on social media
because they go on social media it
doesn't mean that they're going on
social media's cause of anxiety and
depression it might be the other way
around or it might be a correlation with
these other things
your concept
is i think you made your argument and uh
thank you very much so be seated and
jonathan you have a right to respond
yeah so certainly i certainly understand
that correlation does not show causation
and that's why in our giant google
document we have a section on the
correlational studies we have a section
on the experimental studies and the
studies that use random assignment also
find effect so we're quite confident
that it's not just reverse correlation
or third factor if there is a causal
effect um secondly
secondly hold on let me answer sir hold
on no excuse me excuse me sir sir so
there's a lot of people who want to
speak unfortunately unfortunately the
protocol is you just get one shot
and and yeah and uh come to the party
afterwards and grab the guy by to talk
to you
and in terms of percent variance
accounted for this is what i was saying
about dose response versus emergent
effects if all we had was dose response
i would agree with you that the
correlate the variance we can explain by
the correlations is not adequate to
explain this gigantic catastrophe that's
happened i would agree with you on that
and that's why a lot of what i've been
doing in my writing and what i did in my
atlantic article a couple months ago was
to say stop looking just at dose
response this is a network
transformation this affects kids who
don't use social media at all because
before they could find other kids to
play with and now they can't you that
you don't pick that up in the
correlations of the kid who doesn't use
social media because it's a network
transformation it's not just just
response
uh comment uh actually could you
elaborate on that point a little bit i
think it's the part of your analysis i
was actually least persuaded about that
you know what
you're saying it's right it's not just
affecting the kids who are heavy social
media users but because there's so much
heavy social media use there aren't
enough dissenting kids to like find each
other and it's so changing the
the environment like is there enough
scientific evidence of that yet though
is that really just like a theory for
how this is impacting yeah well so the
other big piece that i haven't brought
up here in terms of the depression uh
explosion is the vast overprotection
that we put on kids in the 1990s kids
need to play they need to play
unsupervised they learn how to work
things out um and we largely stopped
them from doing that in the 1990s we
decreased the amount of free play this i
believe made kids more vulnerable weaker
and then those same kids get on social
media and now i feel like i could do
that great woody allen movement where he
pulls out marshall mcluhan i happen to
have lenore skinesia right here lenore
can you stand up please
hello hello
[Applause]
so this is what i mean by a network
transformation um before 2009 there's
data from a british studio so in 2009 it
was something like 60 or 70 of english
girls said they sometimes went over to
their friends houses and in 2014 2015 it
was like 12
yeah well that's i fully agree that
that's bad i'm lenore's editor reason i
edit all her things that but that
doesn't get to the um i mean the
government has criminalized doing this
right the government should do less on
this front agreed agrees government
should make it legal to play at the park
okay
out of the playground and on to social
media next question
uh both focused on
the impact for children i was wondering
if you could focus a little bit on the
impact for grown-ups naturally we know
about our attention span getting mushed
up but i was thinking if the definition
of social media was something to do with
an app in which we posted content so
that we could uh share and connect
would dating apps be connected within
this and if the uh algorithms are
playing with the date with the dating
apps because naturally it's not their
objective to get us paired up and live
happily ever after but instead to spend
enormous amounts of time constantly
looking
could
the dating apps be considered the social
media that could be actually generating
a
civilizational impact on how we
procreate develop and have families and
children i guess that's the question for
jonathan as well
yeah i guess we'll do yeah i'll um so i
i agree with your premise i think you're
probably right i just read an amazing
book a wonderful book by cal newport
called deep work and it really affected
me in terms of the way that i try to
work and it really helped me stay off
twitter things like that so i suspect
that these
that adults are also very affected and i
think the dating apps
probably are affecting emerging
sexuality uh
among young men and women um i simply
haven't studied it yet so i don't know
what i'm basically i think it's
affecting them in a negative way
from um
from
uh i get yes overall um but there i'm
not but i'm not confident i have not
reviewed the research and there isn't a
lot of research what i've been doing is
looking where the light is best which is
on children there are a lot of studies
we have a lot of data large large
studies i haven't seen any good studies
other than like you know decreases in
how much people are having sex they're
things like that and stories but i just
so i think you're probably right but i
don't know comment from you robbie
better
again
in so many of these things we're talking
about i agree that a subset a minority
of users can have negative experiences
with these things i mean maybe this
comes down to like a philosophical thing
i like i am not going to have the
government restrict access to these
platforms on everyone's behalf because a
small amount of users are having an
issue just like i wouldn't make gambling
illegal because some people go to the
casino and they'll bet everything they
have um most people can go and have a
good experience that's just maybe it's
just like a libertarian philosophical
thing dating apps i would tend to think
have tremendous ups i mean i don't use
them but uh they
have like made it easier for people to
find more prospective partners um
they've probably been very valuable to
like the lgbt community and others who
you it'd be hard to especially if you
live not in a big city but it's hard to
know like what your prospective dating
pool is there are a lot of advantages so
let's not you know as we focus on the
harms in a couple categories
which i agree there are harm like again
let's not lose the tremendous upside of
at the you know click of a button at
your fingertips having an entire world
of people to engage with date have
conversations with and so on and so on
moderators prerogative i would not have
met my abstract artist downtown wife but
for a dating app
is there a
balcony
balcony
balcony
i was about to say the balcony thank you
we're up here yeah yeah uh yes uh and
are you up at the balcony yes indeed and
uh that's i was about to recognize you
so please ask a question go ahead um so
as we're discussing the decline in girls
mental health
i think it's important to note that
we've devalued girls and their
contributions we've told them that their
import impulses toward
love and motherhood and relationships
are wrong we've told them that sex is an
emotionless enterprise designed for
pleasure and that they should indulge in
porn and porn culture
we've reinforced reinforced gender
stereotypes through gender identity
ideology and don't you think that the
intense pornification of girls
and sex has something to do with the
loneliness and isolation and feeling
like trash not just
social media
that's the question uh let me ask you
robbie uh just as a change of pace to be
the first to answer that challenging
question
yeah look porn uh does present um
specific challenges certainly maybe this
would be an area where i think at least
the
the government may be doing some of the
restrictions that you've mentioned for
the other things
certainly you could make a stronger or a
case that would be less affected by the
first amendment because the supreme
court has been more open to regulation
on this front i think the public
pressure put on porn companies in the
last two years
was
porn companies at porn platforms pornhub
uh was positive actually i i agree i
think
them allowing is that pornhub would
allow unverified users to post
pornographic videos without any
ch check like
is allowing for a lot of um revenge porn
like posting without people's permission
which is actually i think the biggest
problem in this category of issues uh
and it may be an area where the
liability protection actually i would
like i would be okay with being tweaked
but because of the pressure and the
credit card companies saying this is you
know we you can't we're not going to
engage with these sites if they do this
they did they changed it so you can no
longer just like post at will without
pornhub having any idea who you are the
idea being then if you post without your
permission they can like give your
information to the cops and something so
i'd like to add on to what robbie said
by pointing out that in his book to your
credit that is one of the place where
you very clearly say here is a case
where i think government regulation is
actually necessary and good so really
it's really just a difference of degree
between us and i want to also emphasize
when we're talking especially as the
conversation moves to adults i'm really
reluctant to tell adults what they can
and can't do so like banning dating apps
like i would never consider like no i
would not think of that
but for children it's very different
children go through developmental
periods development appropriate periods
and so the concern there especially i
think what what i'm learning recently as
i listen to girls especially it's going
through puberty while posting photos of
yourself that's the most vulnerable spot
that's why i think the most damage is
done so i think their development
appropriate periods and finally i think
we both agree and i would really want to
emphasize this as an academic my god do
we need research if there are these big
things happening we certainly don't want
to just go off and legislate because
people think it's a problem because
that's how all the previous moral panics
happened we need this to be a research
priority the surgeon general just issued
this advisory and the surgeon general
reached out to me and and uh lenora is
talking with him next week the surgeon
general is very interested in the
possibility that free play is beneficial
and social media early is not but if
we're going to legislate i mean that's
part of the reason why we have the
surgeon general not just to talk to the
people but to be a kind of a science
advisor all of this has to be based on
research and right now we have very
little
uh i'm going to recognize the balcony a
bit later as well uh back to the
orchestra ask a question please
thank you fascinating debate um this is
kind of going back to the first couple
of questions but
isn't it really reductive and therefore
incomplete to only be focusing on this
one aspect rather than looking at the
incredible complexity of young people's
lives and that does include their
awareness of climate change um
uh
financial issues for sure school
shootings i mean this is the generation
that grew up
really genuinely fear fearing as
unlikely as it actually is that they
someone's going to come into their
school and shoot them so i mean
i i know we're kind of returning to the
earlier points but
i just feel like you know this is not
factoring in just how incredibly complex
and difficult people's lives are now
yeah i mean i think we probably both
agree with that i would just say i don't
think that's a social media
that is not a thing you can specifically
blame on social media i mean fear about
mass shootings is one of the is one of
the mainstream media's like biggest uh
biggest things that gets wrong frankly
because like as you said they are uh
blessedly extremely rich school
shootings are especially extremely rare
um kids are there's all sorts of
statistics you can look at but like kids
are safer at school than other
environments generally so the the fear
that kids have that they're going to die
in school is
to a large degree an un irrational fear
compared to other ways they might harm
themselves or come to harm but it is
such a such a powerful fear that you
could see how how that could be one
factor contributing and i suspect it is
one factor contributing to the greater
anxiety of young people for for reasons
that the mainstream media has pushed on
them not social media yeah and i i would
certainly be a fan of both complexifying
uh and simplifying you want to go back
and forth between perspectives and in in
the cuddling american mind greg and i
tried to do that to trace out multiple
there's like six threads that we trace
out i love stories about trends working
together i would just point out people
do not kill themselves because they're
afraid they kill themselves because they
feel alone and so school shootings is
not it might make people afraid it's not
going to make them kill themselves you
kill yourself when you feel disconnected
alone shamed
but certainly factors into anxiety and
depression if they are afraid
um anxiety i suppose i'm not sure about
depression yeah um next question
gentlemen behind thank you
uh sure um my questions for for jonathan
uh so you were talking about earlier
technologies and and how they induced a
moral panic before they retained
and then they got me thinking about the
printing press and whether we never
tamed the printing press because
pretty much anyone can print a pamphlet
or publish a book
but then i thought of libel law how you
can't just print sort of what oh libel
yes libel law and how you can't just
print anything
and
it shocked me that the power of
anti-defamation law as applies to
written text published text
is that it places the onus on the
aggrieved party
to raise that cause of action and to sue
the author the publisher
who printed the untrue and defamatory
statement about them
and so that way rather than having a
regulatory agency or congress
trying to design a one fits-all solution
the regulations can can sort of
coalesce from the bottom up into
based on a response to actual
circumstances
so my question for you is could you
imagine
a uh the creation of a new cause of
action a private cause of action perhaps
at the federal level so it fits with any
resolution
that would
provide the persons who have been harmed
by specific intentional actions of the
the purveyors of social media the social
media companies
that would then realign incentives in
order to address the uh
the harms that social media causes well
i i see what you're trying to do in sort
of changing systemic pressures and
changing systems that you get a better
outcome um but the last thing i would
want in our litigious culture is to say
we're going to resolve this by
individuals taking action against each
other what i would much rather we do i
think your example of the printing press
is a very good one because it's an
example of incredibly powerful
technology that brought down old and
decrepit power structures and part of
that is happening a part of it is
beneficially referred to that about the
vested interests are the ones who are
most threatened um
but i
but i think it's a good example as with
so many of these technologies that yeah
we did need a little bit of regulation
and i think there does have to be some
regulation here and especially as i said
you know the british example where what
they're doing with their online harms
bill is they're positing a duty of care
that if you're a platform that is having
minors on you have a duty of care
they're not like you're you know it's
okay if you know if you want to just
exploit your adults and for their data
you know they're they're adults where
they make their own decisions but with
children you have a duty of care so i
would rather that we have uh like not
the heavy-handed kind of regulation if
philip howard was here many of you know
philip howard and his his books and his
analysis of of how terrible and stupid
most regulation is but when you lay out
a general principle and you let the
companies figure out how to meet it
don't try to micromanage so yes i think
that the printing press is instructive
in many ways but i would not want to see
just mass action i mean we're already
attacking each other all the time to put
penalties and fines on it too would just
make it unbearable i think coming from
you robbie no no okay yeah
uh balcony question hi thank you thank
you both for a really engaging debate um
the big tobacco question seems very
relevant because we're framing social
media as essentially an addictive
substance that hijacks our biology and
so we need federal government to step in
and save our brains and our bodies
essentially especially those of our kids
um if i have a history right though and
forgive me if this is really hopelessly
libertarian um the federal government
response to big tobacco only came after
there was a really strong social science
consensus that tobacco was harmful and
it seems that we're still cobbling
together some sort of consensus exact
consensus about social media so i guess
my question is
is there a reason to believe that once a
really strong consensus emerges that
there won't be more of a grassroots
response from parents and even from kids
themselves
um about how they're going to change how
they relate to social media which will
then change how platforms appeal to them
um and is there a reason to believe that
won't happen or the federal government
could do this more efficiently than
parents or the kids themselves yeah
you're right that there's no consensus
in fact if you took all the people who
say that they're social media
researchers i would say the majority of
them are skeptical that social media is
a cause and gene twenge and i are the
main people who are in a debate there
are a few others who are on our side but
we are actually right now the minority
position i believe that's because
they're all focused just on the dose
response data that's all and there's so
much more going on now if there was and
so if there was to be a consensus would
this suddenly galvanize the nation like
no i don't think galvanization and data
tend to go together very well um or i
wish they did but they don't um so
that's why i'm hoping you know let's
take small steps based on uh oh and one
of the main things that lenore and i are
talking with the surgeon general about
is
here are the experiments that would
learn that would not settle but here are
the experiments that would tell us
because what we need to do is school by
school don't just like tell one kid to
use more or less have an entire school
district have a phone locker policy and
have the next school district not have
it and we'll know in two years whether
it was beneficial so um so i'm very
reluctant again to tell adults what to
do but yeah when it's kids we really
need to do research on what on what's
harming them and if it's not harming
them then i wouldn't want bands and and
just to add i really do expect it'll be
something new the k like there is
i have very little faith that kids will
continue to be interested in the social
media sites that are popular right now
there's such turnover in this space the
the ones that have have been around now
for a while are you know declining in
popularity i mean i this is even true
for me i and i'm a very active i was a
very active social media user i realized
the other day that i use twitter a lot
less all of a sudden um i i'm using
instagram less i don't use facebook at
all i'm not going to get into tick-tock
so it some some of these things will
have a natural lifespan and either the
next thing that comes along could be
healthier even for kids for the
population we're talking about then
instagram is this could be a this could
be a one-off because again the problem
even based on what you're saying it's
not really
social media it's this platform for
these people
which i agree but i would never make
government policy at that i mean it's
very hard and then even among that
population you'd have still the majority
of girls in that age group using
instagram responsibly and not having a
negative you you know you have i think
it was like two out of five right in
that in the facebook internal data or
something yeah but again that's the dose
response thing yeah well yeah they'd all
be better off if they didn't have it as
my argument i don't yeah i don't think
so um another question is about today
okay thank you uh my question is to
jonathan on instagram specifically at
the same time that there are young girls
incentivizing a certain type of body or
a lifestyle
they are that make girls uh feel bad
about themselves or trying to fit into a
world that they will never fit at the
same time however we have many profile
accounts telling them
accept yourself it is okay to be
whatever you want to be
so you don't think in this regard social
media can auto regulate themselves
and you don't think it must be a choice
for the users to follow what make they
feel better
or in the case of minors you don't think
the parents should be responsible for
helping them like
parents cannot
see what the kids are doing all the time
so the government will never
be able to do this
so that's my question okay yes thank you
if we just look at content if we thought
that you know all that matters here is
content just like what the kids see and
then we say well you know maybe if we
can get maybe there's a lot of good
content and maybe if the good content is
ten times the amount of bad content
maybe that'll be okay
but my argument as a social psychologist
is that it's not primarily about the
content
it's about
going through middle school which is
already the worst time of life for most
people it's always been worse for girls
going through middle school where most
of your consciousness even when you're
in class most of your consciousness is
about the drama going on and it's about
the photo that you posted and it's kids
are learning to be brand managers and
performers when they should be out
playing and so i don't focus very much
on the content and that's why i'm not
very interested in content moderation
it's a whack-a-mole game it's a hopeless
errand i'm focused on the dynamics
especially the social dynamics and i
think these platforms are unsafe at any
speed for young kids especially around
12 13 14. anything photo based and the
girls go for the photo based platforms
the boys went for video games and also
for youtube um back in the early 2010s
um the second part of your question was
um oh shoot what was it uh what are we
people choosing uh the parents yes can't
the parents do it um so you know if it's
if it's like how much candy well a
parent can control how much candy you
eat in your own house but it's hard to
control outside of course instagram and
these platforms are a little different
because um it's like
you imagine that a candy company
contracted with your daughter
to hook up a pipeline of candy into her
bedroom and no permission is needed for
your parent parents don't even know
they just do it and they do it all over
the world
and you can't stop it because yeah if
you're really vigilant you could you
could catch it at the window but then as
long as you can get to a web browser
she'll get it so these companies are
going around our backs they're putting
us in a trap none of us very few of us
want our kids to be on but they're in a
it's a it's a classic economic social
dilemma where we each give in because we
don't want our kids to be isolated so i
think this really calls out for some
central force to break the trap
especially when we're talking about
underage kids i've had two conversations
with mark zuckerberg two conversations
with adam oseri i bring this up every
time and they always say oh but we don't
allow kids under 13. well after my
second after my first conversation with
mark zuckerberg for the second i just
created a fake account for my daughter
and i lied about her age i said oh yeah
mark really i just made an account for
her so you know it's a trap it's illegal
well i understand
especially for under 13 there's no
excuse for this i think
um i'm afraid uh we're running out of
time uh and uh robbie
make a brief comment if you want yeah it
just
it will be very hard no matter how
interested the government is doing this
from stopping from like this is a genie
that cannot be put back into the bottle
uh like kids will find ways to access
these sites we should actu absolutely
empower
parents local decision maker you know
school counselors should talk to people
about responses talk to the vulnerable
group the the young women i i think they
should talk to young men as well about
uh porn addiction again we're not
totally clear on what the research tells
us these are absolute conversations that
you should be having in the school but
the level of banning and prohibiting
they're going to get around it and we
could we could make these these
platforms seem more seductive and more
tempting because now they're part of the
forbidden ah thank you for excellent
questions we're running out of time in
the q a uh we're going to move to the
summary portion of the evening jonathan
height
speaking for the affirmative please take
the uh
okay well thank you gene thank you
robbie thank you to the audience
i'm extremely interested in the power
and importance of viewpoint diversity
and especially as we saw tonight
you have two people we agree on a lot we
disagree on a lot
and this was fun and we both come out
with more refined more nuanced
views of a very complicated very very
important topic
in my closing remarks i just want to um
let's see i want to make a couple of
points
um
let's see
okay i'll
so suppose
here's a thought experiment i've been
playing with i want to i'll try to work
it out here um suppose we're back in
1993 uh before most people had really
seen seeing the internet and imagine
that a genie appeared and he he put in
front of us three magical boxes just
floating in the air in front of you
and and he said you can open
none one two you can open as many as you
want or none of them
and on the first one
the label said internet the second one
it said iphone and the third it said
social media
now knowing what we know now
which ones do you think we should have
opened or which ones would you choose to
open or which ones do you think were
good for society to open
so let's do let's let's do a little poll
so suppose so the internet
uh so
you know obviously enormous benefits and
yeah there are some downsides i mean
lots of things can happen on the
internet that are bad um raise your hand
if you think we'd be better off if we
didn't have the internet raise your hand
high
okay one
and now raise your hand if you think no
it's a really good thing that we have
the intent raise your hand okay it's
like an insane question especially in
room full of libertarians
so the internet i mean the cost-benefit
ratio the transformative effects of the
internet the things it made possible the
things it brought outside of wealthy
countries and made available to people
all over the world
it's transformative in a good way like
electricity or like fire so the internet
boy are we glad we opened that one and
remember for some of you if you're old
enough like me it's like
you know the first time you see it in a
web browser like
it was it was inconceivable it's like
all the information like
there for free
amazing
all right next one
the iphone
now smartphones it's a little more
complicated because there are claims
that smartphones have damaged a
generation smartphones are addictive
things like that but this is the most
amazing swiss army knife ever created
and i sleep with mine under my pillow
because it's useful as a flashlight and
useful as a clock and i go everywhere
with it um and you know as steve jobs
originally intended it was going to be
like a swiss army knife with these like
five or six
things that are tools that you can use
now in some ways now it uses us but
we'll get to that as a swiss army knife
i think this is an incredible thing
now do you think that the world would be
better off if we never had smartphones
if we all were just on flip phones raise
your hand if you think we should not
open that box
okay so now we get about about 10 people
saying yeah we'd be better off if we
didn't have smartphones just flip phones
raise your hand if you think no it's a
good thing we have smartphones raise
your hand okay so about 90 all right
okay now we come to the third box and
remember each box you open is going to
take 10 to 20 hours a week from you
okay now
what do you get for the internet you get
a lot you learn a lot
what do you get from from your iphone it
solves a lot of problems finding you
taxis all sorts of things
so each each time you open a box it's an
extra 10 to 20 hours okay so now we're
up to 20 to 30 hours a week from
internet and smartphones okay now
there's a third box it says social media
it says facebook or instagram social
media
now if you open it what do you get
you get constant updates about what
someone had for lunch and why someone
hates somebody and why somebody is a
fascist or a racist
and
and what are the downsides well i've
been making a case that there are many
many downsides
so what i'd like you to do is imagine
imagine a world without
without social media imagine uh imagine
a world in which the only way you could
communicate with other people
was by phone
email
texting whatsapp skype zoom facetime
blogging fortnite roblox minecraft a
thousand other video games multiplayer
games u.s mail and walking over to
someone's house ringing the doorbell and
using your vocal cords
imagine such a world robbie said we
should be grateful that we had social
media during the pandemic no we should
be grateful that we had these 50 other
platforms that could connect us our kids
would have been so much better off if
they had to actually zoom each other
rather than posting posting posting
company oh you look great love it like
no that was stupid that was a wait that
was not connecting that was performing
we would have been so much better off if
we did not have social media of that
business model if we just had everything
else
that at least is my claim um so um uh so
if in conclusion um if you're happy that
we open that third box and you think
everything's going fine and you think we
shouldn't exert some some kind of of a
centralized effort to try to clean
things up uh research based of course
but if you're happy with the way things
are going you should vote after after
these statements you should vote no on
the resolution
but
if you join me in imagining a better
world healthier kids and a more
admirable democracy i urge you to vote
yes thank you
[Applause]
someone said once maybe they didn't
maybe i said it all debates eventually
become debates over definition so i
would like to go over those lists of
things you just mentioned that we're
good and like is that doesn't count as
social media again if we confine social
media to just the experience teenage
girls have on instagram yes it's not
great right uh but so many people are
using things
we just would describe social media i
would describe
aol instant messenger and myspace the
things i used when i was a teenager to
great enjoyment to have much better uh
friend much larger friend groups to make
friends i was a shy kid i didn't make a
lot of friends in school i made them
after school on in what is clearly
described as social media i think i i
bet that's the experience i anecdotally
i hear this from young people that is
the experience still of a lot of kids
that
school school the people the class
they're sorted into that they would have
been lucky to be sorted into in normal
times but have not been sorted into
because they've not actually even been
in school for two years
is not as enjoyable as the networks they
can curate and create for themselves
because of this amazing
technology that i would not that i would
absolutely open that box and unleash on
the world because you don't have to use
it the choice is still yours you can
unplug some people can unplug we hear i
think a lot from the loudest angriest
and most addicted people which warps
this conversation the social dilemma
movie which you were were you the only
person in my view giving like saying
saying normal saying things in that
netflix documentary which is mostly
about all these former tech people
bragging about how they think they've
hacked your brain and that your
decisions are no longer your own and
they control you and isn't it bad but
also kind of cool what they were able to
do like they're bragging that they did
this i'm listening to these people and
like you know you're tech addicts like
you you you people who worked for these
companies and were involved i get that
you're a little bit too addicted and too
in love and obsessed in an unhealthy way
with this product is this most people's
experience i don't think it is
uh we didn't talk about this as much
jonathan sort of started to suggest that
it the quasi-nefarious
thing these these these platforms are
doing in that they cut they're
collecting data about you and then
seller selling a curated your user
experience and providing you with
advertisements i'm so i'm
pro-capitalism so i don't think this is
necessarily as malicious as it's made
out to be
i can watch television all day and be
bombarded by advertisements for products
that are irrelevant to my interest that
i have no interest in buying but when i
visit social media i am shown things
that might actually improve my life that
i might want to buy i'm not forced to
buy them the kind of like it's hypnotism
is like i don't believe that maybe it's
their social psychologist again bragging
about their own achievements trying to
say that this is something they've
created i don't believe it i i think
it's it's it largely can be can be a
benefit so we've concentrated a lot in
these remarks because jonathan is such
an expert on it and and it's an
important topic you know the harms to
kids element of it but i you know i just
want to remind you that that's probably
like 25 of the conversation right now
about why the government needs to do
something about social media most of the
energy
attention to this issue is focused
either on um
the spread limiting the spread of
misinformation that's the major liberal
concern and then on right something we
didn't even touch here tonight is the
concern that that these uh that the
platforms are are censoring too much
information um so those are the and my
my book if you're interested in it gets
into those a lot a lot more because they
really are the things we're talking
about so you know i just wanted to say
30 seconds again
on those before we wrap that i think uh
the the whatever legitimate beefs there
are uh
do not lend themselves whatsoever to a
government solution which is the the
question on the table and in fact
the interest that the government has in
regulating social media along these
lines and not this not the stuff where
there maybe is some cause for concern uh
is is illustrative and should give us
pause about pursuing any inviting in any
capacity the government uh to do more
about this and and on the misinformation
question specifically because really
this is the the i would i don't i'm not
sure what your take would be i think
this is the major reason people want to
regulate social media these days at
least the one i come into contact with
the most
here the research is
is very favorable i i think to my
position
a lot of the the panic about how much
people being inundated with so many lies
and et cetera et cetera is has not been
borne out uh by the data actually it's
it's like a tiny number of social media
users who are sharing the most
like alarming social media
misinformation it's a tiny number of
users who are seeing it it pales in
comparison to the misinformation they're
inundated with in the on the media
platforms that existed before it uh but
this is the animating concern of the
biden administration and the ftc and the
fcc of the government figures who
actually will do the regulating who are
going to do something on social media
this is what they care about and it will
have very bad consequences for free
speech thank you
[Applause]
uh conor please open the voting please
take out your smart phones and
please vote yes no or undecided you
could still be undecided on the
resolution if you were undecided uh
before or if you voted yes or no again
the federal government should
increase its efforts to reduce the harms
caused by social media uh yes no or
undecided on the resolution drum roll
please
[Applause]
now um the resolution um
the uh the resolution uh got initially
28
of the vote
it rose to 37.7
percent it picked up
9.8 percentage points 9.8 percentage
points is what you picked up jonathan
and that's the number to beat the no
votes also picked up but picked up 1.8
percentage votes therefore the tootsie
roll goes to jonathan height
congratulations john congratulations
[Music]